president's treasury secretary now
admits she was wrong about rising
inflation secretary janet yellen told
cnn she did not expect the shocks to the
economy that led to the biggest price
hikes in 40 years yesterday the
president met with yellen federal
reserve chairman jerome powell to
discuss plans to lower inflation mr
biden said that is his top econo
economic priority consumer prices jumped
8.3 percent last month that's compared
to a year ago that's a big jump carter
evans spoke to small business owners who
made it through the pandemic but now
they're scared rising prices will shut
them down
after two years of pandemic challenges
erica gutierrez's mexican heritage shop
in pasadena california is still just
hanging on are you taking a paycheck
no not yet
how are you surviving
well off my savings and
you know my family's support the city
gave her a ten thousand dollar grant to
get by but that money is long gone and
now she's struggling with inflation we
now have to
pay more for products we have to pay a
lot more for shipping are you afraid you
might run out of business oh yeah all
the time every day nationally 85 percent
of small businesses experienced
financial challenges in the last year
and right now optimism among those
owners is at its lowest level in nearly
50 years this was a bike shop pasadena
chamber of commerce president paul
little says the city's lost about 15
percent of its businesses since the
pandemic began this restaurant was here
for 40 years what's it like now when you
look and see all the weeds growing here
well it's kind of sad a sign of the
times down this part of historic route
66. the pandemic hammered everybody we
all got to a point where we thought well
at least we can get back to some measure
of
a normal but it's even more challenging
now inflation has really presented
another challenge to businesses how much
more can they take well exactly where is
that tipping point when they finally say
i can't do this anymore gutierrez had
hoped to hire another employee by now
instead she may have to look for a
second job
that's a very real thing because i do
have to figure out how to bring income
to my home for cbs morning's carter
evans pasadena california